bonjour Yannick jado bonjour vous êtes
sénateur écologiste de Paris nous sommes
ensemble pendant une vingtaine de
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale qui
est représentée aujourd'hui par Christel
Bertrand journaliste politique au groupe
La Dépêche du Midi bonjour Christelle
alandre bonjour forcément commencer par
évoquer cette grogne des agriculteurs et
d'abord ce drame une agricultrice et sa
fille sont morts hier à Pamier dans un
accident de voiture sur le barrage
d'agriculteur à Pamier donc dans le
département de lariège est-ce que vous
craignez que ce drame ne fasse dégénérer
cette crise agricole dans le pays
écoutez je pense que tout le monde est
terrifié par ce drame on devrait jamais
mourir quand on milite quand on
s'engage une femme FME une jeune fille
qui sont décédées donc on est avec la
famille on est avec les proches on est
avec celles et ceux qui qui s'engag pour
défendre leur métier pour défendre
l'agriculture et évidemment il faudrait
pas que ce drame au fond euh et des
conséquences plus dramatiques encore
ailleurs donc je pense que tout le monde
je pense que tout le monde a compris que
on avait tous une responsabilité pour ne
pas instrumentaliser ce drame à des fins
politiciennes c'est un drame absolu
encore une fois les écologistes disent
toutes leur leur condoléance à la
famille et aux proches vous voyez des
gens l'instrumentaliser aujourd'hui dans
la class politiquecoutez on voit en
permanence celles et ceux qui veulent
mettre de l'huile sur le feu qui
instrumentalisent la colère des
agricultrices et des agriculteurs qui
veulent en faire leur leur levier de
conquête politique on pense notamment on
pense notamment à l'extrême droite qui
qui c'est toujours foutu des
agriculteurs qui vous le savez par
construction est anti-européenne et donc
il faut quand même rappeler au aux
agricultrices et aux agriculteurs que si
ils ont pu participer à la
reconstruction de l'Europe et ça été un
élément central de la reconstruction de
l'Europe de la construction après-gerre
de notre souveraineté alimentaire c'est
grâce à une politique européenne
ambitieuse qui tous les ans ou transfère
plus de 9 milliards d'euros vers les
agricultri agricultur c'est le
rassemblement national aujourd'hui qui
progresse dans les campagnes et pas les
écologistes est-ce que vous avez raté
quelque
chose probablement mais je pense que
c'est
surtout ça fait 40 ans qu'on rate
quelque chose avec l'agriculteur avec on
a un modèle qui aujourd'hui est
profondément inégalitaire 80 % des aides
de la politique agricole commune donc 80
% des premier budget européen vont vers
20 % des agriculteurs les plus important
le système de la politique agricole
commun parce qu'il faut faut expliquer
aux téléspectatrices aux téléspectateurs
c'est plus vous produisez plus vous avez
d'hectar plus vous touchez et donc dans
ce monde aujourd'hui très instable
explosion du coup des intrants marchés
internationaux très instables
libéraliste
libre échange dans ce Mondel vous avez
le le le le le piège qui a été tendu et
construit aussi malheureusement par la
FNSEA c'est de dire au fond c'est ce que
certains paysans appellent le
cannibalisme agricole c'estàdire qu'en
fait vous ne pouvez survivre qu'en
prenant le le le le la ferme d'à côté
qui est en train de s'écrouler les
petits disparaissent 27 fermes par jour
disparaissent et ça c'est la
responsabilité de la FNSEA le principal
Sy
la politique agricole française est
construite depuis 40 ans entre les
gouvernements de gauche et de droite et
la FNSA la politique agricole commune
c'est une construction française parce
que il y a pas une agriculture il y a
plusieurs agricultures dans notre pays
vous voyez bien que celles et ceux qui
sont aujourd'hui piégé par l'endettement
piégé par l'explosion des coûts piégé
par l'agroindustri
qui fait des marges extraordinaires
piégé par le dérèglement climatique
c'est pas les mêmes que y compris
Monsieur Arnaud Rousseau patron de la
FNSEA qui vit très bien du commerce
international qui vit très bien de
l'agroindustrie et au fond qui vit très
bien des marges de l'agro-industrie qui
se font sur le dos des petits
agriculteurs alors sur le plan politique
cette crise agricole c'est le baptême du
feu pour le nouveau Premier ministre
Gabriel Atal Gabriel Attal qui hier à
l'Assemblée nationale a cibler les
oppositions et précisément les
écologistes je le cite il s'adressait
aux écologistes vos larmes pour nos
agriculteurs ressemblent à des larmes de
crocodil vous présentez souvent les
agriculteurs comme des bandits des
pollueurs de nots teres des
tortionnaires de nos animaux et à chaque
fois que les agriculteurs ont un projet
d'extension qui s'y oppose c'est vous
Yannick jado qu'est-ce que vous répondez
à Gabriel atalan je pense que c'est
irresponsable c'est lâche et c'est assez
minable en fait euh le Premier ministre
visiblement continue c'est pas une
nouveuté avec ce pouvoir malheureusement
ça fait suite à d'autres gouvernements à
une totale irresponsabilité en matière
d'agriculture encore une
fois on a des paysanes et des paysans
qui on le sait aujourd'hui le monde est
très instable tout le monde dans la
société et terrifié par l'avenir parce
qu'on voit qu'à chaque fois les droits
sociaux sont reniés on voit les guerres
on voit l'instabilité on voit les chocs
du dérèglement climatique et ben pour
les agricultristes et les agriculteurs
c'est puissance 10 dans
PZ le dérgltique c'est la catastrophe
absolue quand il fait vous le savez bien
quand il fait 40 45 degrés par canicule
au niveau du sol des vignes c'est comme
si vous mettiez un coup de chalumeau sur
le raisin il y a plus d'eau mais pour et
donc qu'est-ce que dit qu'est-ce que dit
le Premier ministre il dit mais tout ça
c'est la faute des écologistes tout ça
c'est la responsabilité il trouve un
boum plutôt que de travailler des
solution les agriculteurs veulent des
mégabassines les agriculteurs veulent
utiliser plus de produits
phytosanitaires pour justement pas lier
à ce problème comment expliquez-vous
qu'aujourd'hui votre discours écologiste
ne ne percolle pas chez les agriculteurs
mais écoutez un euh je conteste ce que
vous dites parce que ça voudrait dire
qu'en fait c'est ignoré et mépriser les
milliers d'agriculteurs qui passent à
l'agroécologie qui passe au bio qui se
disent si je veux poursuivre
mon métier non seulement il faut que
j'ai un revenu et il faut travailler sur
le revenu la Confédération paysane a
raison de dire que c'est scandaleux
quand les l'aval de l'alimentation ne
paye pas les prix au au mieux au coup de
reviens c'est scandaleux de payer en
dessous du coup de rev mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que ignorer renvoyer aux
écologistes la crise agricole c'est
ignorer le débat qui doit y avoir au
sein de la profession agricole dans la
profession agricole il il en a qui
jouent des marchés internationaux et qui
de fait acceptent les traités de libre
éch dit sur les barrages aujourd'hui
c'est on norogique moi par exemple la ha
la hausse des taxes sur le gazol non
routier est-ce qu'il faut abandonner
cette ha tax le mot norme est utilisé
aujourd'hui comme un comme un gros mot
vous vous rendez compte mais la norme
c'est ce qui protège notre santé allez
demander au bretons ils aimeraient bien
avoir des norme pour empêcher les algues
vertes l'taque l'attaque sur le Gazo non
routier est ce qu'il faut revenir dessus
mais voyez comment moi on a le même
débat qu'avec la taxe carbone nous on
s'est toujours battu contre parce pour
qu'à chaque fois qu'il y a une fiscalité
écologique elle soit reversée aux
acteurs pour les aider à faire la
transition et là ce que dit la
profession agricole dans encore une fois
dans des avec des agricultrices et qui
sont piégés aujourd'hui vous avez près
d'un près de deux suicides par jour vous
avez un/4 de la profession qui vit sous
le seuil de pauvreté et qu'est-ce qu'on
fait plutôt que de résoudre cette crise
là on dit c'est la faute des écologistes
encore une fois c'est minable parce que
le dérèglement climatique il est là la
raréfaction de l'eau elle est là c'est
pas en inventant de l'eau dans des
bassines alors qu'il pleut plus et qu'on
on peut plus en consommer pour nous-mêm
qu'on va résoudre les problèmes donc
encore une fois juste là-dessus il y a
le sujet de la politique agricole
commune si le gouvernement doit agir
c'est un contraindre les marges de la
transformation et de la GR industrie
elles ont explosé au au détriment des
paysans de les aides doivent aller à aux
unités de production c'estd plus vous
avez de salariés plus vous touchez plus
vous respectez la nature plus vous
touchez c'est le contraire aujourd'hui
question de sécurité pour clore cette
page sur la crise agricole yannque jado
est-ce que le gouvernement doit ordonner
l'évacuation de ces barrages routiers
est-ce qu'il y a un deux poids de mesure
par rapport à la gestion de certains
blocag des mants écologistes éident ah
bah il est évident si vous voulez vous
avez dernière rénovation qui bloque une
autoroute sur la question du climat
pendant un quart d'heure ils sont en
garde à vue et euh les procès tombent et
les sanctions tombent euh là on est les
écologistes les écologist ferait le
millième de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
il serait en prison et condamné c'est et
d'ailleurs c'est pas le débat
d'aujourd'hui mais c'est quand même
étonnant de voir que dans notre pays
quand on défend l'intérêt général on est
immédiatement sanctionné quand on défend
des intérêts corporatistes qui sont
légitime aujourd'hui on n' pas les mêmes
réponses que la fnso ça c'est évident
mais cette colère- làà nous nous on veut
sortir les agriculteurs du piège dans
lequel ils sont et c'est pas en ignorant
la nature qu'on résoudra le problème
vous dites il faut lever les barrages
aujourd'hui je dis qu'il faut répondre
aux agricultrices et aux agriculteurs
moi j'ai moi je suis je fais partie des
gens qui qui j'ai fait de la
désobéissance civile donc j'ai pas de
problème avec les mouvements de
protestation la responsabilité du
gouvernement c'est pas d'ignorer la
crise écologique et de servir les
intérêts des plus gros dans
l'agriculture c'est enfin de répondre à
à la disparition des paysanes et des
paysans qui sont terrifiés qui sont
malmenés précarisés en les accompagnant
la politique agricole dans notre pays
c'est 13 milliards d'euros par jour par
an pardon une famille de 4atre personnes
contribue à hauteur de 800 € pour
l'agriculture par an on peut avoir
l'exigence d'aider les paysanes et les
paysans et non pas les intérêts de
l'agroindustrie ou des pesticides
yannique Jad on a parlé de
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
puisque aujourd'hui l'Assemblée
nationale devrait adopter euh sans
surprise euh le projet de loi qui
propose d'introduire dans la
Constitution ce droit à l'IVG le texte
doit ensuite être adopté dans les mêmes
termes au Sénat et hier le président du
Sénat jar Larché a exprimé son
opposition à cette réforme
constitutionnelle est-ce qu'il est en
train d'enterrer euh cette réforme pour
renforcer lesvg non euh heureusement euh
moi je regrette la position euh du
président du Sénat euh mais euh c'est
pas nouveau qu'il est contre ça a pas
permis euh l'adoption d'une résolution
au Sénat donc j'appelle les sénatrices
et les sénateurs à être responsable de
ce point de vue on voit dans les
différents pays y compris qui sont en
train d'être menacés ou menés par des
coalitions d'extrême droite et de droite
d'extrême droite et de droite revenir
sur le droit à l'avortement donc le
mettre dans la Constitution c'est
protéger le droit à l'avortement alors
que encore une fois regardez dans le
monde quand les extrême droite et la
droite gouverne ils remettent jamais en
cause la concentration des richesses ils
remettent jamais en cause le libéralisme
ils remettent jamais en cause donc à la
fin qu'est-ce qu'il remettent en cause
il remettent en cause les droits de la
société ils remettent en cause des
droits il contestent la diversité de la
société aujourd'hui le rassemblement
national n'est pas opposé à l'avortement
est-ce qu'il y a un risque en France
pour que ce soit remise en question
c'est la raison quijours toujours
toujours à partir du moment où on le
voit y compris dans certains
départements la difficulté de
l'accès pas au droit mais à la réalité
de l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse ça dit bien que c'est jamais
acquis ça se dit bien que c'est toujours
un combat et moi je regrette les
positions très conservatrices de
certains et de certaines alors demain le
Conseil constitutionnel va se prononcer
sur la loi immigration qui a été adoptée
par le Parlement en décembre dernier et
les sages du Conseil constitutionnel
pourrait censurer plusieurs
durcissements du texte ajouté par les
républicains notamment le durcissement
de l'accès aux aides sociales pour les
étrangers finalement le Conseil
constitutionnel c'est le dernier espoir
de la gauche sur cette lo immigration
c'est un c'est terrible que ce soit
qu'on considère le Conseil
constitutionnel comme un espoir
d'ailleurs le président du Conseil
constitutionnel pour le moins à Taner le
président de la République sur la
responsabilité du du président des
législateurs on avait Gérald armanin qui
expliquait devant la représentation
sénatoriale oh ben écoutez vot ce que
vous voulez de toute façon ce sera
sanctionné par le Conseil consel c'est
totalement irresponsable moi ce que je
trouve dramatique sur ce débat c'est ce
que j'appelle la la rupture trumpiste de
ce quinquen non pas que Emmanuel Macron
soit devenu Donald Trump même si sa
dernière conférence sentait un peu quand
même travail famille patrie mais c'est
une rupture trumpis parce que pour la
première fois dans notre pays et j'ai
entendu madame Boyer parler avant au
fond on débat plus de la même Ré ité
c'est en ça que c'est trumpist trumpist
a amené dans le débat européen le fait
que on ne parlait plus de la vérité mais
qu'il y avait des vérités des vérités
alternatives et qu'elles étaient
équivalentes et ben dans le débat sur
l'immigration quand vous entendez la
droite dire après l'extrême droite ça
ruine le pays c'est faux ça ruine pas le
pays au plus bas c'est neutre sur les
finances publiques mais ça contribue
plutôt à la richesse du pays quand on
dit il va y avoir des appels d'air c'est
faux il y a pas une une étude pas une
enquête qui montre que régulariser des
travailleurs sans papier c'est faire un
appel d'air au contraire c'est
participer à la prospérité au-delà de
sortir des gens de la précarité et de
l'invisibilité ou de la clandestinité et
ce texte qui était censé être un texte
sur l'immigration sanctionne les
étrangers qui travaillent parfaitement
légalement dans notre pays sur les
prestations sociales c'est ce qu'on
appelle la préférence nationale et donc
c'est une rupture trumpiste au sens où
ça existait déjà il fallait il faut 5
ans de résidence régulière pour avoir le
RSA la c'est pas c'est pas le même type
de droit mais euh euh et c'est pas
forcément une bonne nouvelle mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que par le débat sur
les retraites on avait des positions
différentes mais on partait du corps on
partait de la même du même diagnostique
sur l'avenir de nos retraite là le
président de la République son
gouvernement sous emprise de l'extrême
droite sur ce sujet a choisi de faire
une loi sur des mensonges des
contrevérités du complletisme ça c'est
grave ou il y une inie la mais parce
qu'elle est constru cette opinion quand
depuis des années on dit l'immigration
est incontrôlable quand on dit l'aide
médicale d'État ça coûte et c'est un
scandale quand on dit on est envahi que
la France fait plus que les autres mais
tout ça sont des mensonges pourqu est-
plus pourquoi est-ce que c'est plus
audible que ce que vous dites vous à
parce que dans une société je le
regrette mais c'est aussi voyez le débat
sur les retraites à un moment donné il y
avait les positions des uns et des
autres et puis a eu des experts les
journalistes vous avez fait intervenir
par exemple quelqu'un comme Michel
Zemour qui a dit la vérité sur la loi et
ben ça s'est pas fait sur l'immigration
et on n pas eu dans dans dans dans une
société inquiète l'essentialisation de
l'étranger et là l'essentialisation de
l'immigré c'est un ressort énorme c'est
le bouc émissaire aussi vieux que
l'humanité est vieille mais ça dit
jamais qu'on va dans la bonne direction
ça dit qu'on va toujours vers les
extrêmes droitees le repli le rejet la
haine et ça c'est très dangereux et
Emmanuel Macron a participé à ça c'est
très grave Yannick jado on va parler du
groupe pétrolier Total ennergie puisque
demain c'est le début des auditions de
la commission d'enquête du Sénat sur le
groupe Total énergie une commission
d'enquête à l'initiative des sénateurs
écologistes vous en êtes le rapporteur
et cette enquête elle porte je cite sur
le non respect des engagements
climatiques de Total énergie pouvant
alimenter des situations de corruption à
quelle situation de corruption vous
faites référence mais vous avez dans
beaucoup de pays
aujourd'hui que ce soit on le voit avec
le Qatar on le voit en azerbaïjan on le
voit au Mozambique en Ouganda en
Tanzanie on le voit dans plein de pays
où finalement l'exploitation
pétrolière conduit à des situations
d'insécurité de violation profonde des
droits humains de l'État de droit et
nous voulons justement à travers cette
commission voir si à la fois les outils
de politique publique permettent quand
il quand ça concerne le premier groupe
énergéticien français de mieux encadré
mais vous avez total qui est le deuxième
groupe au monde aller chercher le plus
de pétrole et de gaz
quand l'agence internationaleénergie le
JC les Nations Unies disent il faut
arrêter sinon c'est le drame absolu
c'est l'effondrement climatiqu dont sont
victimes en premier lieu dans leur
activité les paysanes et les paysans et
et vous avez par exemple quand quelques
jours avant que le président alief de
l'Azerbaïjan lance lesépuration ethnique
sur les Arméniens du haut cararabach
vous avez le président pouyané qui est
en train de signer un contrat de gaz
avec le président aliè d'azerbaidan
reconnaissez que officiellement
officiellement notre politique étrangère
est en soutien des Arméniens mais il
convient quand même de s'interroger
comment le premier groupe énergéticien
français signe avec celles et ceux qui
sont à la fois des dictateurs et sont en
totale contradiction avec ce qu'on est
censé défendre en matière de politique
étrangère justement la commission
d'enquête souhaite auditionner le PDG
total Patrick pouyané est-ce qu'il a
répondu à la convocation si oui quand
elle quand est-ce que cette audition
aura lieu écoutez euh vous savez que une
commission d'enquête a des prérogatives
importantes des compétences importantes
notamment un pouvoir de convocation donc
je n'imagine pas que le président
pouyanais les ministres et les anciens
ministres qui
euh devront répondre à nos questions à
notre enquête euh viendront et ça sera
évidemment à la fin de la commission
d'enquête parce que on va s'interroger
on va s'intéresser à ce qui se passe là
où intervient total euh encore une fois
euh c'est pas possible que le premier
groupe d'énergie français contribue au
chaos climatique quand on sait à quel
point ça remet en cause nos conditions
d'existence et au fond interviennent
dans des pays qui sont tellement
éloigner de nos valeurs en matière de
droits humains de liberté déoc vous
souhaitez que cette audition de Patrick
poyané soit publique ou à HCl je
n'imagine pas qu'elle soit pas publique
en je veux dire je pense que les
Françaises et les Français sont
intéressés moi j'aurais envie d'être
fier du premier groupe d'énergie
français j'aurais envie que imaginez que
Total en plus de Shelle de BP d'exon
mett tout leur pouvoir économique au
service de la transition énergétique
mais on gagne la bataille du climat en
10 ans et au lieu de ça parce qu'il
gagne gagnent tellement d'argent ils
servent tellement leurs action ils
goinfent ils gavent leurs actionnaires
de profit total c'est 40 milliards
l'année dernière de profit sur le dos
des automobilistes comme sur le dos du
climat et ben j'aimerais qu'ils mettent
leur pouvoir leur savoir leurs
compétences au service de l'intérêt
général et non pas simplement au service
de leurs actionnaires le groupe Total
énergie vous a attaqué pour diffamation
pour vos propos sur le groupe pendant la
campagne présidentielle 2022 on en est
où de cette affaire judiciaire mais elle
est euh je suis mis en examen parce
qu'effectivement total a considéré que
questionner le maintien de la présence
de Total en Russie après l'invasion de
l'Ukraine souvenez-vous tous les grands
groupes internationaux quittent la
Russie pour ne pas être complice de
l'effort de guerre de Poutine alors que
déjà les crimes de guerre de Poutine
étaient démontrés avec les bombardements
de la la société civile et vous avez le
le groupe français qui reste en Russie
et donc qui de de fait puisque les
autres sortaient pour ne pas être
complice de fait étaient complice de des
activités et de l'effort de guerre de
Poutine est-ce que c'est est-ce que
c'est un débat public illégitime et vous
considérez qu'il est normal que un
groupe attaque des élus attaque des les
personnes qui critiquent encore une fois
la présence de Total en Russie alors
qu'ils sont ils étaient en train de
massacrer les Ukrainiens est-ce que vous
craignez que comme vous êtes mis en
examen dans une affaire avec Total et
bien certains des énonce et mettre en
cause votre objectivité dans cette
commission d'enquête parlementaire vous
savez il est quand même si euh euh le
comité d'ontologie du Sénat doit rendre
sa réponse ce sera quand ce sera dans
les heures qui viennent euh il serait je
trouve dramatique mais c'est la
responsabilité du Comité de déontologie
que l'instrumentalisation de la justice
pour faire taire toute critique
vis-à-vis du groupe Total soit
légitimité par le comité d'ontologie on
verra ce qui dira mais vous savez quand
j'ai dit ça j'ai dit ça sur des plateaux
de France Télévision la patronne de
France Télévision a aussi été mise en
examen pour diffamation c'estàdire qu'il
a une volonté de total de faire faire
toute critique mais vous rendez compte
que si on valide cette
instrumentalisation de la justice qu'on
appelle des procédures billons mais ça
sera facile maintenant pour un groupe
comme laactalis qui maltraite les
éleveurs laitiers en Bretagne et
ailleurs il suffira que euh il il porte
plainte pour diffamation à chaque fois
qu'il y a un responsable politique qui
ose une critique pour dire et ben c'est
bien comme ça ils pourront même plus
légiférer sur mon comportement vis-à-vis
des éleveurs on finit par une dernière
question sur les euréenes ou un peu de
politique la campagne des européennes a
commencé c'est Raphaël gluxman qui
remble pour l'instant à avoir le vent en
poupe il a organisé un weekend à gauche
en tous les cas il a organisé un meeting
ce weekend à Bordeaux qui s'est
relativement bien passé est-ce que vous
pourquoi est-ce que vous joignez pas vos
forces pour réaliser un score qui fasse
poids vous savez il y a qu'est-ce qui
vous oppose fondamentalement ici
Emmanuel Macron devait faire en fait
vaut mieux qu'il arrête d'agir parce
qu'à chaque fois qu'il agit il agit dans
le mauvais sens aujourd'hui
malheureusement mais s'il devait faire
une chose c'est de mettre la
proportionnelle à l'Assemblée nationale
pour qu'on sorte d'un système politique
de confrontation pourquoi je vous dis ça
parce qu'au Parlement européen c'est la
proportionnelle à un tour donc moi si
raphaë gluxman arrive à obtenir le
maximum de députés socialistes au
Parlement européen que manombri arrive à
rassembler le maximum son électorat pour
avir le plus de députés que les
écologistes qui sont les derniers à
défendre l'agenda écologique qui sont
les derniers à défendre l'agenda
écologique quand tout le monde le
conteste parfois de manière je l'ai dit
assez minable par par le Premier
ministre et ben c'est ça la
proportionnelle à un tour rassemblons
autour de nos spécificités de nos
différences qui sont pas irrémédiables
mais rassemblons au maximum électeurs ay
le maximum deputés au Parlement c'est à
ça ça ser par vous dites qu' y a pas de
différence fondamentale entre nous mais
c'est c'est paré qu'on fera les
meilleurs scores final ça s'appelle la
proportionnelle ça s'appelle la
proportionnelle que chacun valorise ses
spécificités ses différences nous ne
sommes pas socialistes ils ne sont pas
écologistes ça veut pas dire qu'on a pas
un
souci fort les uns et les autres de
l'Europe ce qui est la différence avec
les insoumis mais nous sommes différents
vous le savez en Occitanie comme
ailleurs on n pas toujours d'accord par
exemple sur les projets autoroutiers et
valorisons nos différences que rap guman
aille défendre dans sa campagne
européenne la 69 ça permettra un débat
sympathique de de plateau télévisé merci
beaucoupan d'avoir été notre invité
politique merci beaucououp Christel
Bertrand d'avoir représenté la presse
régionale et pour le groupe La Dépêche
du Midi tout de suite le club des
territoires